tesoro ambiental o turístico la
respuesta queda en el aire por ahora la
gran barrera de coral de australia no
entró en la lista de patrimonio mundial
amenazado de la unesco inscrito en la
lista de la onu en 1981 en junio de este
año la institución cultural de naciones
unidas recomendó traspasar a la
clasificación de patrimonio en peligro
al mayor arrecife de coral del mundo
2300 kilómetros sobre los que reposa uno
de los ecosistemas con mayor
biodiversidad del planeta una sugerencia
a la que el ejecutivo de camberra se
opuso por motivos económicos según
denuncian los grupos conservacionistas y
el gobierno de australia sostiene que
dejar la barrera de coral fuera de la
lista de la unesco es bueno para el
turismo no creo que eso sea así la
verdadera amenaza para el turismo que
visita la gran barrera es la relación de
amor de australia con los combustibles
fósiles
distintos estudios señalan el deterioro
de la gran barrera causado por el cambio
climático el aumento de la temperatura
del mar y la disminución de la calidad
del agua causada por la polución
aceleran la muerte del coral y los
propios científicos del gobierno
australiano dicen que la barrera de
coral estaba en muy malas condiciones y
que continúa deteriorándose es difícil
imaginar cuánto más en peligro puede
estar este arrecife claramente lo que
está triunfando aquí son los intereses
en juego la agenda no la ciencia no el
sentido común ni lo mejor para la gran
barrera de coral de momento queda
pospuesta hasta 2022 la decisión sobre
este pilar de la biodiversidad marina
situado en aguas de uno de los países
más contaminantes del planeta